all right hi everybody thanks for coming
this is rhapsody in zero knowledge my
name is Tony our Siri I'm the co-founder
of a company called occlusion our name
and our logo hints at our desire to move
to zero knowledge protocols what this
talk is about this is a fairly complete
history of zero knowledge proof as much
as I can fit into a talk this long it's
also going to be a giant wall of papers
and for that I apologize but hopefully
you learned something that's what this
talk is not is the math of zero
knowledge produce so fortunately if he
came here expecting to leave learning
how to do the mathematics of zero
knowledge proof that's not going to be
the case I did that deliberately because
I've been to talks like that and I
inevitably come out like this so I've
also lots of a mathematician more of a
historian and journalist so I it would
be better for both of us to just do the
history so start this talk off with I
like to talk about this problem of
identity theft
so originates in two places so there's
data breaches so people can't keep data
secure unfortunately a lot of that data
they can't keep secure things like
Social Security numbers mother's maiden
names we have all these really lousy and
secure authentication methods that make
it easy for people to steal their
identity if that data gets stolen and
worse companies engage in this sort of
surveillance capitalism where they like
to collect this data or risk these data
breaches and perhaps there are ways
where they don't need to hoard this data
to get the business value they want out
of it so what are some solutions well we
don't really have many like one of them
is you give your data to another company
after the first company gets breached
and they monitor it and then maybe they
get breach too so that doesn't seem to
be working very well
another is a move to stronger
authentication mechanisms these are
things like national ID programs but I
feel many other people feel that these
have some rather frightening privacy
implications and to highlight some of
those have a Pet Shop Boys song if it'll
work here
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so yeah that was integral over
at the pet shop boys in 2006 shortly
before the giant NSA debacle with mark
Klein bill Binney and eventually Snowden
would happen so they're a little bit
ahead of their time
so that whole thing it's allegory to
this book by a Gavin ezm yatin called we
this is the archetype for the modern
dystopia in this book
everybody is identified by a number and
they're called numbers but what's really
about is that QR code they're embedded
in the video links to this thing so it
was the UK in 2006 was pushing for this
national ID card program and several
people pushed back against it including
a Pet Shop Boys singer Neil Tennant who
quit his support of the Labour Party
over it you'll see a lot of text in
there the government officials trying to
reassure us that there's no privacy
downsides to this whatsoever it's all
for all for your benefit there I'll to
keep you safe
and right now your telephone is
broadcasting all sorts of numbers all
these static identifiers for you in this
MZ number your mobile subscriber
identity your Wi-Fi MAC and your
Bluetooth identifier and oh by the way
there's this whole Real ID thing coming
so your if you have one of these this
will also we have a RFID chip inside of
there so zero knowledge proof
offer a solution to this what if we
didn't have to sacrifice privacy to get
this sort of security so that's what
this talk is all about so what is is
zero knowledge proof so we start out
with a thing we want to prove in this
case we want to prove you found this guy
if you want to prove you found him in
zero knowledge so say we have you know
this tip
well how do we prove in ceará knowledge
we found them oh there you go yeah we
found him this way you might be thinking
is perhaps you can deduce his location
in air based on its position relative
the edges of this mask paper but hey
there's a solution for that too I just
kind of make this thing big enough so
that's you can't really figure any
information out about where he's located
based on that so this is called a proof
of knowledge consists of two things so
we've got a proof statement this is the
thing we want to prove to prove you
found that guy and then we have
something satisfying that proof in the
terminology of proof and knowledge this
is known as a witness see zero knowledge
stir proof is a proof where we can
demonstrate we have that witness but we
don't reveal any information about it
these two are really the main two behind
the creation of this entire field
Shafi Goldwasser and Silvia McCauley I
want to highlight Shafi in particular
any recent poll among cryptographers she
was voted the most influential woman in
cryptography and yet I think nobody
outside of cryptography has ever heard
of her if he thought this quote was
pretty compelling that's actually a
Shafi quote I had another one in the
abstract for my talk so much of this
talk comes from Chevy's previous talks
I've kind of purloined a lot of her
ideas and just learned a lot about the
history of zero knowledge piece from her
so in 1982 Shafi and Sylvia were working
on this idea called probabilistic
encryption and published this paper
called how to play a mental poker in
this paper they talk about replacing a
trap door function which is this idea
from public key cryptography so RSA is
based on this trapdoor function where
you know the factoring of a the prime
factorization of a number so you replace
it with probabilistic encryption and you
get this thing that works a lot like
public key cryptography where it is very
easy to do if you know a particular
magic number and then the goal is it
becomes easy to prove if you know that
and hard if you do not the entire field
is based on complexity theory so if
you're familiar with complexity classes
like P and NP all these proof statements
are generally in NP but it's that same
sort of field but adapted into
cryptographic applications so it's Shafi
and Sylvia I wanted to do was go from
this idea of probabilistic encryption to
zero knowledge proof and fortunately you
know creating an entire new field within
cryptography is treated with a lot of
skepticism so probabilistic encryption
which is cool among Lee reviewers and
publishers because I had the word
encryption in it but cryptographers
don't generally do proofs ah so this is
a story of if at first you don't succeed
try try again so in the intervening
years they published many papers they
tried to publish this one it was
rejected next year try this one again I
rejected again as information content of
proof system was rejected knowledge
complexity of interactive protocols or
be there yet
nope and it was until 1985 that they
published the knowledge complexity of
interactive proof systems which was
pretty much the foundational of paper
for the entire field of zero knowledge
proof in this they define what a zero
knowledge proof is it is a proof whose
witness reveals no additional
information
yeah this is a interactive proof system
so what is one of those so if you go to
Wikipedia the page four is Iran's proofs
you might see this thing but I don't
think it really explains much and Shafi
hates it so we're not gonna do it so
instead we're gonna do something a
little bit different this is an example
of proving knowledge of a graph three
coloring algorithm so in this example
we're gonna have a couple people here
you might be familiar with Alice and Bob
from cryptography but in zero knowledge
proof we use a little bit different
casts so we got Peggy our prover and
Victor our verifier it's in this example
Peggy knows a three coloring algorithm
for graphs and what she wants to do is
prove it to victor but prove it to
Victor in zero knowledge so we are going
to three little hats on all of the
vertices of this graph after Peggy has
colored it and then we're gonna let
Victor do is select an edge that he
wants to reveal and we will reveal those
two nodes if they don't match we've
gained a little tiny bit of confidence
that maybe Peggy's algorithm works
so we've gained you know this little
insignificant amount the actual formula
there ends up being 1 minus the number
of edges minus 1 over the number of
edges so not very much confidence but a
little but what's cool is if we have
Peggy recolor the graph like so and
repeat this process over and over again
we will gain more confidence mister here
is a cool little interactive web demo of
this thing and as we select more and
more of these edges we gain more and
more coffee
it's that peggy's graph coloring
algorithm actually works so that same
year in 1985 we had one of these
interesting sort of like Newton Leibnitz
moments where two people who came up to
the same with a very similar solution to
the same problem as this other one was
called Arthur Merlin proofs by this guy
b'bye
in this paper trading group theory for
randomness so in this his Peggy is King
Arthur and his victory sorry
his Peggy is Merlin and his Peggy is
victor is King Arthur so this solves a
slightly different problem I'll get into
that in a bit but it had a cool a few
cool quotes and cool ideas as it's
waxing philosophical about proofs one of
the things I mentions is proofs are
meaningless without a verifier so even
if you're mechanically tracking a proof
something is checking your proof but
otherwise proofs are generally made to
convince people of something
additionally zero knowledge proof in
particular you were trying to convince a
distrustful party of something so we
really have a threat model around this
sort of thing so next year in 1986
Shafi wrote a paper about both of these
papers kind of comparing them and
showing that these two proof systems
have equivalent proofing power but there
was a subtle difference between them was
the significant versus private coin and
just in case you're worried he might
have wandered into a black chain talk I
will remind to you this is 1986 and none
of those things existed what's it
talking about it's talking about a coin
flipping protocol and how you would
generate proofs about coin flips
so these fall into two categories one is
this public coin argument of knowledge
where
the outcome of the coin flip is publicly
visible to everyone and then this other
one private coin where you flip the coin
in secret and want to prove that it was
flipped according to some algorithm
without revealing the outcome of the
coin flip so that same year these two
people Fiat and Shamir you might know
Amir as the us in RSA published this
paper on identity protocols and did
something pretty interesting they took
one of these interactive algorithms and
they turned it into a signature so the
important point about signatures is that
they're non Interactive's you're trying
to prove something to someone off line
so the way they did this
so a interactive protocol would be
structured by Peggy giving a commitment
to Victor a victor sending Peggy a
random challenge and Peggy sending back
a proof that incorporates both the
commitment and the random challenge so
to make this a non interactive protocol
we need to get rid of that first round
trip there so the way they did that was
they decided to compete the commitment
with a random Oracle which is a fancy
way of saying a hash function in this
particular case so they've changed a
protocol to be Peggy stole creates a
commitment but we can replace the
commitment with a hash or we can replace
the challenge with the hash of the
commitment and then Peggy stole sons
back the proof and then this eliminates
the need for Victor to participate in
those first steps of that protocol so
this is a non interactive public coin
argument of knowledge and this is the
foundation of pretty much every modern
digital signature algorithm or at least
the ones that are secure so that's all
good but what about
non-interactive private coin argument of
knowledge so this would be far more
interesting right so get back to that
but one more very important thing from
the eighties in 1988 we had basically
the who's who cryptography at the time
write this paper
that says everything provable is
provable in zero knowledge the LDR of
this is every problem in NP is this area
of knowledge interactive proof where in
other words zero knowledge proof are
universal so getting back to that a non
interactive private coin argument of
knowledge problem 1992 you we had one of
the first foundational developments in
this and it kind of hints back to my
original an example there with a graph
coloring so the question they're trying
to answer is let's say you're given this
you know enormously large proof right
like some mathematician has given you a
hundred page proof it's you know I read
the entire thing or check the entire
thing so how would you attempt to
ascertain whether or not this proof is
valid so they came up with this idea
called probabilistically checkable proof
sir the nuance of this is the naive way
of doing this and attempting to prove
that you probabilistically proved you
had checked enough of the proof to be
sure your proof would just kind of grow
and boundedly so really their
fundamental core insight here was to
create a a proof that whose size would
not grow unbounded ly a while still
allowing you to prove that you had
sucked enough of the proof to be sure
and this was a kind of the entry point
to this whole idea of how can we create
smaller proofs and then we got one of
the two foundational advancements
towards and non-owner
active proofs so the first was by this
guy Joe Killian and then the second
would come in 1998 we see Soviet
miquellee again here and he introduces
this idea of computationally sound
proofs and yeah all that many of these
papers contain many of these interesting
quotes waxing philosophical about the
nature of proofs but he developed this
notion of a proof which has poly
logarithmic verification time so it's
efficient to verify and these two papers
taken together are the first example of
something called snogs or a succinct non
interactive argument in 2001 we got
something similar to fiat Shamir where
where fiat shamira worked in the random
Oracle model this developed a new model
for taking that interactive part of the
proofs offline so this was something
called the common reference string model
or CRS but you may have heard this
referred to you as a trusted set of so
you make this very large string using
mathematics where if it's done in an
untrusted manner it can potentially be
unraveled so this is interesting in that
it takes it takes the proof offline and
it's a little scary and that it requires
this initial trust do you get the whole
thing to work until 2007 we got the
first paper really describing a
practical offline
interactor non-interactive proof system
based upon this and this is pretty much
the foundation of everything else I'm
going to present here so 2009 we got
Bitcoin lots of people love Bitcoin
bitcoin is a problem though doesn't have
any privacy
so bitcoin was often originally
described by people as being anonymous
they back pedaled on that started
calling it pseudonymous to me having
worked in security for payments
companies I think pseudonym Adia doesn't
really provide you much this is easily
revealed through techniques like graph
clustering so in 2014 a bunch of
cryptographers he thought you know the
core ideas behind Bitcoin are a little
bit interesting but wanted jihad privacy
he got together and created Z cash one
of them was this guy alia Ben Sasse on
and together they wrote this paper on
zero cash so zero cash is built on
another oddly named idea called ZK
snarks or zero knowledge succinct non
interactive arguments of knowledge so
the zero coin paper wasn't actually
aware snarks were introduced I kind of
glossed over that but it was the first
practical application of easing them to
solve this idea of shielded transactions
or how to hide payments on a public
blockchain it's a quick overview of ZK
snarks so they take the zero knowledge
proof and realized them as something
called algebraic circuits sort of
similar to electronic circuits but
mathematical this particular
implementation 'is weird elliptic curves
so they have this weird property called
the violin or bilinear pairing
pretty so most elliptic curves just
don't work with them this operates in
that common reference string models are
required a trusted setup and it fits
into something called a rank one
constraint system so this describes a
matrix in which all of these constraints
fits and you can think of each of these
constraints as mapping to a single gate
in that outer breaks are good it's a
quick example one of these constraints
how would you do boolean's with these
constraints so constraint you can use to
represent boolean's is x times X minus 1
equals 0 another way you can think of
this as x squared minus ax equals 0 but
there are only two valid solutions for
this say 0 and 1 so in 2015
Elya been sessom wrote another paper on
this idea of taking these special types
of okhta curves and creating something
called a recursive proof this allows you
to prove that you have knowledge of a
previous solution to a proof or yo dawg
i heard you like zero knowledge proof so
I put some proofs in your proofs
so these rely on something called
elliptic curve cycles so it requires you
have two elliptic curves that have a
special mathematical structure where
they're kind of bonded to each other so
there is elliptic curves have a scalar
field so the scalar field of 1 maps to
the point field of another and vice
versa so we get back to that problem I
was highlighting earlier of that trusted
set up so z cash people and trying to
lunch z cashed it all sorts of crazy
things to get it off the ground like
there and the ceremony to create the
common reference string with something
called a multi-party computation and
then proceeded to destroy
their computers in the hopes this would
convince everybody that that sort of
mathematical toxic waste of the truck
and trusted set up was destroyed
unfortunately this was insufficient they
accidentally leaked that toxic waste
three of these ceremony transcripts
they're trying to publish a transcript
proving that they had done the process
carolien accidentally at least the dogs
leaked the toxic waste said that was bad
it's really it would be great if we
could just get rid of that they tried
one thing that was kind of interesting
it was called powers of tau the idea
being that they could have this
prolonged ceremony to have hundreds of
people or more participates in the
creation of this common reference string
anybody here participate in powers of
tau okay I just want then 2017 we
finally got a couple good solutions one
is GK Starks which I'll talk about a bit
later cuz the paper wasn't published
until 2018
but first I'll talk about bulletproof
so bullet proofs are a weight are a type
of non-interactive
zero knowledge proof they have a small
proof size so kind of some of the
properties of snarks they don't have
trusted set up hurray so they solve that
problem also uses a normal lip to curves
so they aren't these weird ones are
required bilinear pairings they're delia
suited for range proofs so the example I
gave of boolean's and those constraints
right that's kind of the degenerate form
of a range proofs or range proof can
prove that a value is in a particular
range without revealing it this is
important for zero knowledge
cryptocurrencies because otherwise
somebody might give you a negative
number instead of a positive one and
then you might think your transaction
balances would
they just gave you negative money the
only drawback of these is the
verification time increases with the
number of arguments Rasmus marks it's
fixed
so 2018 we got that ZK Stark Thanos
talking about earlier so this is Ilya
Ben Sasse onigen so ZK snarks Starks are
built on symmetric cryptography which is
cool because unlike elliptic curves they
will be secure in a world where a large
quantum computer that can break the
discrete log problem exists so they also
eliminate that trusted set up so it
eases this concept that's similar to
erasure coding to try to generate the
crs in a way that no one can gain
advantage I'm wondering what it is uses
a slightly more abstract and complicated
model than these rank 1 constraint
systems
it's called err probably the main
drawback of these is they're
mathematically quite complicated we're
still waiting on a production quality
implementation but fortunately only
events us on create an entire company to
work on creating a production quality
implementation of starts and they have
their work in progress Lib start up on
github also this year we got something
called the coder protocol which i think
is pretty cool so they built a proof of
stake blockchain on reserve recursive
zero-knowledge briefs and so they have
this fun little image there so if you
were building a database and you're
doing a log based replication as soon as
your log is so far behind that you know
your log is bigger than your entire
database of states that's the point at
which you should probably switch to
state based or application right and
just send the entire state normally a
block trades can't do that because they
need
the entire history to be proven so what
Koda did was apply these recursive zero
knowledge proof so they always get this
consistent size proof that they have the
longest chain I believe there it says
it's twenty-two kilobytes so to me this
is pretty interesting research so Koda
proves longest chain through those
recursive zk P's it's written in okay mo
ne okay mo fancier few of you so they
also made this cool thing called snarky
so they made a compiler that will take a
subset of Oh camel and realize it as
algebraic circuits by compiling it to
you this set of constraints so this to
be is this pretty awesome idea that we
can compile programs into zero knowledge
proof written in a language otherwise
you might normally use so 2019 we got
kind of that idea on steroids with this
thing called Zack C so this is a similar
idea of being able to do destroy a
distributed verifiable computation
otherwise known as universal verifiable
computation so you can use zero
knowledge proof to prove that any
program even given secret inputs was
executed correctly and another neat
thing you can do is run an encryption
algorithm inside of this program so its
outputs are encrypted your particular
key that you're interested in if I only
lasts two papers here the day my talk
got accepted this paper got published as
a Spartan found a solution to creating a
ZK snarks that have no trusted set up so
that is great and that is where our
story would end except for on Tuesday
there was a rager need
developments the system called halo halo
is kind of the holy grail of what we've
wanted out of zero knowledge freeze for
ever
halo combines these best ideas of snarks
and bulletproof so it gives us a
recursive proofs I bow that proofs do
not support recursive proofs doesn't
require trusted setup and it uses normal
elliptic curves so they don't need this
by a linear pairing property they still
do that use that neat sort of curved
cycle or property to achieve that all
right that's all I got um thanks for
coming
I have time for some questions
we've got one over there
um so I'm probably not the person to ask
about that so most of them are in NP
you're saying like what would happen
sorry I forgot to repeat the question um
so I think you were trying to ask if a
solution to P equals NP were found what
effect that would have on zero knowledge
proof I don't actually know so we are
working on a sort of bridge between the
cryptocurrency systems we work on which
is called cosmos into the easy cash
shielded pool so Z cash has two sets of
addresses right now it has T addresses
which are transparent and Z addresses
which are these zero knowledge ones so
right now there's one way in and out of
ZK shielded pool so we're trying to make
another way so you can move stuff in and
out of the shielded pool directly from
cosmos
so the question was how how does it
handle verifying the history
so my answer that is you don't have to
because it proves that the current state
is correct so to the extent $0 proofs
work they prove the history is correct
[Music]
so yeah the questions about scalability
of recursive proofs I would say trying
to so we're trying to operate hitter
right now so it does add to latency so
the kind of you know publicly visible
systems we work on generally come to
consensus in about six seconds CUDA
they're working on figuring out you know
what they what their latency target is
going to be so generating those proofs
does take time and it does have latency
the cool thing those new nodes can sync
up instantaneously because all they need
is on 22 kilobyte proof so it's it's a
trade-off I'd say yeah
yeah yeah if you want to learn more
Vitalik be Turin has a great series of
blog posts on his personal vlog there is
also probably should have found it and
mentioned it but there is a entire
self-contained paper on ZK snarks that
assumes you know nothing else it's about
75 pages long
unfortunately I didn't get its name
before the talk anybody else you know
okay
yeah yeah so something this would allow
you to do instead of say oh yeah the
question is I guess like what could we
do with Sarah knowledge proofs that's
like public key cryptography but better
so as I was talking about these national
ID programs you could do things like
prove non inclusion on the new flight
list without revealing who you are so
you could just generate or proof on the
fly that says I am not contained within
this log we could prove your age
something like that right so their
properties encoded in let's say a
anonymous credential at somebody's
issued to you you can select which ones
you want to reveal or reveal only this
and you can do this kind of non
interactively without going back to your
certificate authority or if you were
have a credential all right I think
that's it
thanks for coming everyone
[Applause]